Senator Lindsey Graham of South Carolina
joins us now senator you have promised I
want to go to this Lisa page a lot of
credit to congressman Collins in Georgia
mm-hmm last week we got the or testimony
this week right we've got the page we
have all of that 302s gang of eight and
the FISA warrants themselves my question
to you is simple you now do we have to
base on what Lisa Paige said do we now
have to go back right to Hillary Clinton
if in fact the DOJ rigged that from the
get-go
yeah there's two questions I think the
public deserves an answer to did they
short-circuit the Clinton email
investigation because they wanted her to
win and they knew if they charged her
she might lose did they start the
Russian investigation against Trump as
an insurance policy in case he did win
those are the two questions that I'll
try to get you answers to well it also
where's Michael Horowitz where's John
uber because we're also waiting for them
right there's three people going to look
at this Horowitz is going to look at the
FISA abuse did the DOJ corruptly get a
warrant against an American citizen
Carter page
I think they corruptly got a warrant
against Carter page and that should
scare every American you've got the Utah
US Attorney acting as a quasi Muller
when it comes to all things DOJ FBI I
think we need a special counsel to look
at the potential crimes by the
Department of Justice the FBI regarding
the Clinton email investigation in the
Russian investigation against Trump
early on the point is the Congress me
not going to happen in the house we're
going to call them all before the
committee did they try to invoke the
25th amendment to take the president
down did they get a warrant against an
American citizen using information they
know was flawed did they tank the
Clinton email investigation because
they're afraid that if they indicted her
she would lose an election that wanted
her to win you're going to get answers
to that the best I can give him to you
senator this now was brought to an even
higher level what was released yesterday
that is to the Attorney General Loretta
Lynch and office
she do we need her text her emails does
she need to be put under oath and more
importantly what information did she
give to the former President of the
United States what did Obama know and
when did he know it as to all of this
here's the question I've got why would
you decide not to charge her before you
even talk to her the point is it seems
to me they were going to make sure it
didn't go too far that the Department of
Justice under Loretta Lynch was never
going to let this email investigation go
too far before they even talked to her
apparently they decided not to charge
her and when they did talk to her they
talked to her without being under oath
they gave a lot of people immunity in
the Clinton email investigation for no
good reason so here's what I think
happened
I think the Clinton email investigation
was short-circuited because they did not
want to compromise her ability to win
election they hated Trump's guts
they started the beginning of the
Russian investigation before he won as
an insurance policy in case he did win
here's here's another problem this is
why releasing the Pfizer's the 302s gang
of Eight's which i believe i mean i
don't know why the president hasn't
signed off i guessed that probably my
fourth coming I hope he does but here's
the interesting part in Bruce Sora's
testimony last week we we thought we
knew now we know Bruce or said he warned
everybody in all the 2016 Hillary paid
for it's tainted
nobody's verified it nobody's
corroborated Christopher's steel hates
Donald Trump and has an agenda and the
thing is Christopher steel if anyone
said they've verified it we know it's
not true because steel in an
interrogatory in Great Britain he said
he didn't know if it was true himself so
they couldn't verified it but they used
it for FISA warrants it goes a little
deeper than that
so Bruce or is telling the head of the
investigation McCabe and others you
can't rely on this dossier because the
guy who created it hates Trump he's got
a political agenda right so with that
knowledge they asked for a warrant for
different occasions against Carter Paige
and his what McCabe said without the
dossier would never gotten the warrant
they showed us that McKay said that but
it gets worse after Trump wins Comey
gives him a copy of the dossier saying I
want you to know this is out there we
can't verify any of it but I just want
you to know about it it's the same
document they gave to the court under
oath women so close rely on that call me
signed off on the dossier in the ward
actually in October 2016 before Donald
Trump sworn in in January 2017 well
salacious but it's unverified James
Coleman you have a right hand side Hey
how could you tell the court is reliable
until the president well we don't know
if it's true or not because they were
setting them up because they were maybe
setting him up that's right all right
Thank You senator